EDWARD BUCKLES, JR:
We woke up, and my mama
was all over the place,
like, "Yo, we leavin'.
Like, yo,
I'm not asking you.
I'm telling you."
Since the storm, it seems like
everybody just moved on.
In America, especially
during disasters,
Black children
are not even a thought.
Have you ever talked
about this before?
No, I haven't.
BUCKLES: Why, you think?
I don't know. Nobody
really there to ask me.
BUCKLES:
Hurricane Katrina caused
one of the biggest dispersements
of Black people in history.
After losing so much, why
wouldn't anyone ask
if we were okay?
Nobody ever asked the children
how they were doin',
so I am.
Katrina Babies, take one.
Friday, I was at school,
walking the hallways
with my friends.
By Monday, I was on top
a fucking roof.
SPEAKER: Everything you consider
as part of who you are
was reduced to a trash bag.
SPEAKER 2:
Am I gonna die? I don't know.
I just was like,
I'm not supposed to be here.
BUCKLES: The New Orleans
that we knew was gone.
When I got back after Katrina,
I naively thought
that everything
was gon' be normal again.
SPEAKER 3: The feel of community
in New Orleans is different now.
SPEAKER: Your neighborhood
was crucial to who you were.
What we knew to be true
is gone.
Think about what that does
to a community.
It destabilizes it.
SPEAKER 4: I feel like nobody
should be that young
going through shit like that.
SPEAKER 5: They're in homes,
and they don't feel safe.
What does that do
to our children?
It wreaks havoc
on their well-being.
BUCKLES:
Katrina is becoming a folktale,
and we're the storytellers.
Resilience
is when you still find a way
to have your head up
and help yourself.
Sometimes, I feel like
resilience is used as a tool
because they want people
to think,
"Oh, no, everything is okay.
These people are good.
They're strong. Look at how much
they've overcome."
It's for me to say
we're not resilient.
what is resilient.
It's not for you.
SPEAKER: Being able to tell
my Katrina story
has been part
of my healing process.
BUCKLES:
Even though we are resilient,
we can never get back
what was lost.